hey guys I'm Ryan Wright I am Randy
price we're gonna check out the trailer
today the second trailer for pixels now
if I know this audience on the real
rejects they don't like Adam Sandler
very much Jenny but they like Game of
Thrones and Peter Dinklage is in it and
this fanbase may not like Adam Sandler
but they are huge fans of paul blart
mall cop and Kevin James's in this I'm
just kidding no one likes paul Blart
more not even people who watch Palermo
oh really I mean Kevin James so camera
in 1982 NASA launched a time capsule
into space containing examples of our
life and culture in hopes of contacting
extraterrestrial life unfortunately the
message was taken the wrong way
[Music]
I believe that some alien life force
sent down really video games to attack
us that makes sense we need video game
expertise
these guys were champions back in 82 Sam
Brenner pac-man world champion Ludlow
lamonsoff master of centipede also known
as bedding plant king of Donkey Kong
[Music]
[Music]
you're welcome the only way to take down
pac-man is with ghosts those are your
ghosts
[Music]
don't tell anybody I killed a smurf
[Music]
we have this if we don't the world ends
[Music]
we have to take the battle to them
[Music]
daki com1 you suck
[Music]
may I introduce to you the creator of
pac-man compress umetani what are you
doing I would talk to him he's my son oh
[Music]
okay that's the second show that I've
seen for this it just makes me want to
watch it more and more I like it I love
it I think it's so fun it's so inventive
aliens as video game old-school video
game characters coming back to attack us
and taking video game players and making
them art heroes like it's it's different
it's inventive and it looks like a blast
and I like how they have all of the
different ones like and then they have
the specialists for each one as well
yeah and then apparently like he's in
prison and so what they're not gonna let
him out because no Peter debuted in
prison and so they let him out to
finally defeat don't yeah yeah I think
it looks like a total great time you
know like a lot of people don't like
these Sandler movies and Kevin Jeanes
films but this looks different it
doesn't look like that it doesn't look
like Adam Sandler just went on vacation
and filmed the movie it looks like legit
film with an actual budget good
direction of assault I don't know if
it's gonna be a solid script but it
looks like they're actually working off
of a screenplay this time they're just
random banter anything I don't like
about Adam Sandler movies that most
people don't like this film seems to at
least offer something different in terms
of these people coming together to make
this film I'm definitely intrigued by it
it just looks like so much fun
I don't mitt this too often but I
genuinely do like Adams I think he's
funny
I did too you like his movies may not be
that great and sometimes are [ __ ] but
even the shitty ones I like chuckle here
and there because I like Adam Sandler I
think he's really funny and he's a good
dramatic actor it doesn't look like Adam
Sandler is necessarily putting on a
character but still it it just looks
like a total blast I'm sure Peter
Dinklage will steal the show in some way
because he looks like he's the one who's
doing the most
already did even when he's in the little
cuss and he's like yeah and you know I
could see how this could actually become
a franchise in some way like they just
yeah because instead of just taking
old-school video games you know down the
line they could start taking you know
video games from the next generation the
next generation no but there's something
really cool about the 80s effects of the
video games like the Q cubes yeah well I
feel like there's more even of those
games that we could use like what don't
ask me that question don't ask me that
question because if I don't answer this
properly then I'm gonna get a lot of
hatred from gamer fans a little orange
guy Qbert there's that there's also the
one where you're like a plane that just
keeps going forward and you keep
shooting there's a lot of those games oh
yeah
it's like it the one we're at what about
the one with the bouncy ball yeah oh
well Metal Slug is not pixels but Metal
Slug it was [ __ ] sweet you had like
other fighting games to you know add
Street Fighter back then and stuff so
there's other ellika there you go yeah I
got like a the spaceship was Galaga
asteroid so you get a lot more it
doesn't have to just be pixel games I
feel like there's a lot of older games
too that they can use so yeah this could
be a great franchise name but I just
hope this first one is is as fun as the
movies making it look to be because it
looks like it has a level of humor
that's gonna be there obviously but it
also looks like a fun action-adventure
at the same time I wonder really what
happens to the people because you know
it bites his hand and it starts he
starts pixelating but it doesn't does he
turn into a cartoon or does he die or
how does that really work he develops
genital herpes I believe but that he
doesn't die no genital herpes doesn't
kill you yeah but he's still alive in
mmm-hmm okay that works or is a
chlamydia committed there's a cure for
chlamydia yeah I would have used it by
now if it existed alright I have a
serious case of chlamydia anyway guys
thanks for tuning in if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the Rio
rejects you can check out the prices
right channel over here there's a lot of
trailer reactions on there too and you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter where if we get enough followers
we can get product placement meaning
less work for me and no benefit for you
for things such as yes salt shakers salt
shakers are great you know they it just
makes it efficient to get your salt and
you could pour it on food and my
girlfriend's editing right now but if
you're ever in the mood you know for
some type of oral fixation you just add
some salt to it and it's things your
penis it doesn't feel good at all but it
makes it more tasty for her dammit you
were listening try to do these sexual
jokes and fries